foreign
[Music]
foreign
let me be very clear
up to date means you've received your
last dose in in the past nine months
up to date means you've received your
last dose in the past nine months
if you've already received the first
booster that's great and please see if
you're eligible for a second or a third
booster to remain up to date
but my message today more specifically
is for those that haven't yet received
their first booster
the immunity conferred by a primary
series of two doses of vaccines
administered in 2021 has now waned
while you might have gotten infected
risk is high you could get re-infected
with all the downfall including the risk
of developing symptoms of long covet
as health experts and Physicians we'll
tell you it's critical that you go and
get the shot that's waiting for you
maintain our vaccinations
Canada's national advisory committee on
immunization Nasi I strongly recommended
that all people 18 years of age and
older get a first booster dose six
months after their initial vaccines
this applies even if you have previously
had covet 19.
we don't want to return to more
restrictive Public Health measures and
luckily thanks to science we have an
amazing tool that avoid that vaccination
the vaccination foreign
yesterday the national advisory
committee on immunization Nasi released
its interim planning guidance for a fall
2022 covid-19 vaccine Booster Pro
program in Canada to which Dr Tam will
discuss which Dr Tom will discuss in a
moment in her remarks
this is important guidance to support
provinces and territories in their
vaccination program planning and I thank
Nasi for their valuable work
s
all across Canada I want to reiterate
that the Canadian government will
continue to support your vaccination
efforts
the impact of Covenant 19 is essential
to our health and well-being and
vaccination remains one of the most
effective ways to protect against kobit
19 and its impacts
the more people are up to date on their
vaccines the better protected we are as
a community and that means less strain
on our health care workers if you have
not received a covid-19 vaccine yet it's
never too late to start your primary
series
as a country we are privileged to have
access to such an efficient and Powerful
tool in our fight against the virus
let's use it
more about this
well covid-19 activity indicators
including weekly case counts and severe
illness Trends are stable or declining
in many areas covid-19 viruses are still
circulating across the country
despite overall lower transmission
nationally Regional variability
continues
most recently some areas are reporting
increases in disease activity indicators
such as lab test positivity and
Wastewater signals in addition the
proportion of omicron's sub lineage
variance ba4 and particularly ba5 is
increasing among sequence variants in
Canada
given ba4 and ba5 are even more
transmissible and immune invasive than
ba1 and ba2 it is reasonable to expect
that we'll see an increase in cases over
the coming weeks
significantly questions
virus continues to circulate worldwide
and new variants emerge and spread we
must remain Vigilant and prepare for
Resurgence in the weeks and months ahead
keeping up to date with all the covid-19
doses you're eligible for including
booster doses continues to be vitally
important
up-to-date vaccination Remains the
foundation of our protection
individually and collectively to help
reduce the spread that leads to
Resurgence and to significantly lower
the risk of hospitalization and death
due to covert 19.
vaccine Effectiveness data from early
April to through early May 2022 when
Omicron variant activity was very high
in Canada indicate that people
vaccinated with a complete primary
series plus an additional dose of
covid-19 vaccines had approximately five
times lower hospitalization rates and
seven times lower mortality rate
compared to unvaccinated people
Canada's national advisory committee on
immunization on Nasi continues to
monitor the rapidly evolving scientific
data Nazi's latest guidance provides
provinces and territories with
recommendations for planning booster
programs to help prevent a strong
Resurgence in the fall and winter reduce
severe illness outcomes and lesser the
strain on Health Systems
Nasi strongly recommends a primary
series with an authorized mRNA vaccine
in all eligible age groups
Matthew also strongly recommends a
booster for all adults as well as for
adolescents who are considered to be at
high risk for severe disease
while the timing and severity of a
future fall or winter wave is uncertain
Nasi recommends that individuals who are
at increased risk of severe covid-19
illness should be offered a fork of it
vaccine booster dose in those aged 12 to
64 years may be offered a full booster
dose regardless of the number of boosted
doses previously received
booster doses increase protection by
activating your immune response to
restore protection that may have
decreased over time
at this time we continue to closely
monitor the monkeypox situation in
Canada and internationally
currently over 3 400 confirmed cases of
monkey Parks have been reported from 50
countries as of June the 22nd
in Canada as of June the 29th
278 confirmed cases of monkey Parks have
been reported nationally including 202
from Quebec 67 from Ontario five from
Alberta and four from British Columbia
based on the latest epidemiological data
provided the majority of these cases are
male range in age from 20 to 69 years
in line with the international Trends
the majority of cases in Canada to date
reported intimate sexual contact with
other men
however it is important to stress that
the risk of exposure to monkeypox virus
is not exclusive to any group or setting
anyone no matter the gender or sexual
orientation could get infected and
spread the virus if they come into close
contact with someone who has monkey pox
or who have direct contact with their
personal or shared objects including
towels or bed linens
as we continue to enjoy the summer
months including celebrating events like
pride Long weekends and seasonal
festivals let's do our best to enjoy
each other's company safely as tomorrow
is Canada Day I would like to give a
special shout out to people everywhere
in Canada to acknowledge your continued
efforts in helping to co-control coven
19. thanks to our Collective action
including achieving amongst the highest
vaccine coverage in the world and
continuing to adhere to Public Health
measures to reduce spread it is
estimated that hundreds of thousands of
lives were saved in our country alone
our challenge now is to sustain the
gains we have made while not losing
sight of the continuing threat of
covid-19 to our health
many of the preventive actions and good
personal protective habits we have honed
over more than two years of managing
covid-19 can also reduce your risk of
getting infected and spreading other
diseases including monkey pox prevention
starts with keeping all of our
recommended vaccines up to date and
added layers of protection including
hand washing masking in polyvented
latest indoor or crowded settings and
staying home if you have symptoms to
prevent spreading infection to others
thank you merci migrich
foreign thank you I think it's time to
turn some uh turn to some questions
we um
foreign
so
um
received the vaccinations
going from Olivier to Oliver I believe
we have any Bergeron Oliver from CTV in
the line
um please go ahead
thank you very much for taking my
question
um my first one is to minister du Khloe
I'm just wondering if you can explain to
me the rationale for continuing the
arrive Canada app
we well the the better person to answer
that question would be Minister Mandy
Chino with a public safety uh Minister
he would have explained I think just
recently that arrive can obviously been
a very important tool during covid-19
and remains important for uh those
people that enter into Canada to to
identify whether they they are
appropriately vaccinated but
increasingly a Rife count is also being
used to facilitate and accelerate uh
entrance into Canada through customs
data entry which in many cases makes it
quite fast and quite efficient to enter
into Canada using that particular tool
which has been developed for other
purposes to ex to make our custom system
even more efficient
okay uh actually cbsa has said that the
arrive Canada app tends to slow things
down and I assume there was a public
health rationale for keeping it but I
will move on you are here with Dr Tam
today encouraging people to get a third
dose and for months both of you have
been saying that that is far superior to
a two dose Series so why hasn't the
government changed the definition of
fully vaccinated to three doses instead
of two
what where
a we want to build on the success that
we've had with two doses Dr Tam spoke to
that earlier and that success is not a
only a cause for
um
legitimate pride in what we've done
until now but also a source of Hope for
the future because Canadians in such a
large number have received two doses
which used to be called and so still
called primary series fully vaccinated
because we have had so many Canadians
receive those two doses first two doses
we have saved thousands tens of
thousands of lives and hundreds of
thousands of hospitalizations and many
many people not having ended up with
symptoms of long covid healthcare
workers have been better protected
because of our Collective success that
has also helped you know not increase
even further the delays and the
cancellations of Diagnostics and
treatments for non-covid patients it had
obviously protected vulnerable Canadians
and immunocompromised Canadians who
despite the fact that they need baby
maybe vaccinated or not appropriately
and sufficiently protected against
covid-19 reducing infections and
transmission and many other positive
things for the success linked to success
we've had in Canada now that success
tells us that we can look forward to
continuing the fight in the fall we know
covid-19 will be there in the fall I
have talked to my colleagues Ministers
of of Health across provinces and
territories we all know and we all agree
that we need to work together very
closely in the next few weeks while
Canadians have a break a summer break
which they all very much deserve but we
will be active our officials will be
active our Public Health officials will
work together so that we are able
towards the end of the summer and early
in the fall to make sure that as many
Canadians as possible or up to date in
the vaccination status
thank you uh just a reminder if if
you're dialing in to use the um raise
hand function if you wish to ask a
question and a reminder to use some of
the best practices to avoid outside
noise
um
next we have Jamie morker from Global
News please go ahead
hi there
um I want to start off uh with coven and
talk a little bit about the vaccines
that we have coming down the pipe for
different variants so we know that you
know we need production against ba4 ba5
there are some Omicron specific variant
vaccines in the work
will Canada have those in time for fall
and what efforts has the country made to
secure those vaccines
on the science alter introductor Tam and
then I might add a few words on the
procurement Dr Tam
um so manufacturers including uh the MRI
vaccine manufacturers such as Pfizer and
moderna but others too such as novavax
have been looking at uh broadening their
vaccine repertoire by including for
example a Omicron
variant in the vaccine so I think people
have heard about the bivalent vaccine
for example from moderna Pfizer is also
looking at a very similar constructs
you've probably heard about in the
United States the the liberations of the
FDA advice the advisory committee that
advises the FDA so I think the first
step is that we need the data from the
companies and
um some of them have been released in
their Media or briefing materials but we
need them submitted to the regulatory
authorities and that hasn't occurred as
yet in Canada but we hope that they will
submit those to health Canada as soon as
possible all but there is a very
important discussion I think on the
regular very front how do we shift
strains and how do we look at the
benchmarks for Superior superiority of
those strains compared to the existing
ones
so Canada will you know of course
evaluate those vaccines as they come on
board and the timing is is interesting
and that's why I wanted to to explain
the process is that I think
manufacturers have been working on uh
like a ba1
Omicron variant bivalent vaccine some
may be working on ba4 and five but that
hasn't been us
um you know readily available in terms
of data and the timing then of the
availabilities of these vaccines are
dependent on that those steps being done
as quickly as possible and and safely as
possible so
um
you know we don't know as yet I guess is
what I'm saying but people are working
really fast
I I do have to say that just to
reiterate that the current vaccine
um is still very effective against
particularly serious outcomes and deaths
and so getting that booster and using
that at the beginning of the full
campaign is is something that uh can be
done while waiting for the results of
the
um the other vaccines I do think that
right now
um broadening you know looking at ways
to broaden the immune coverage and our
immune response would be a very
important objective
foreign
Minister declote did you want to add to
that
yeah I'll just add briefly that we are
we being the government and Minister
testing particular being the minister
responsible for procurement we're very
actively working with uh with companies
Modena and Pfizer in particular uh to be
ready if uh we need to be ready with the
purchase and delivery of these new
formulations
so sorry it it's just not clear to me
will you know if moderna say or Pfizer
puts in their application will these
will we get enough of these vaccines in
time for fall for this rollout for these
boosters that you're um asking people to
get
well our contracts with uh both
companies allow us to have access to the
most recent formulations of the vaccines
it's it's true that I'll just also flag
that
um of course people are working as fast
as possible timing depends on that
Regulatory and other processes but
I would say that when the vaccines first
roll out it won't be you know we don't
know what the supply is and Nasi will
make certain recommendations for example
for prioritizing uh high-risk
populations perhaps that as they did at
the beginning of the vaccination
campaign depending on the supplies that
we will get
thank you
thank you so much am I able to ask a
second question do I have time Matthew
yes please go ahead
okay
um I just wanted to clarify as well you
know we're talking about not not being
fully vaccinated or not being considered
fully vaccinated whatever the language
you want to use is after that nine month
Mark and getting a booster dose
um I know Tim uh Dr Tam in the past you
have mentioned that you know after six
months is when that immunity can really
start to to wane and potentially even
before can you just clarify a little bit
about how we landed on that nine month
and uh Minister duclow can you be very
clear will you be changing the
um you know what is considered fully
vaccinated the definition of what is
considered fully vaccinated I think
people really just want to know will
that be changed to include a booster
dose or can we be certain that that
won't change
I'll turn we'll turn first to Dr Tom for
the the timing the the different number
of months to which you uh eluded and
then I'll say a few a few words at the
end on on up-to-date vaccination
yeah so from the national advisory
community on immunizations perspective
they recommend an interval of six months
between the second dose and the booster
that first booster dose
um and uh but you know provinces can
also uh depending on the epidemiology
and context uh shift that to shorter
time frames and some of them did
and people can also wait three months
after they got infected to get the
booster shots so even after infection
it's recommended you get that booster
and so um I think what Mr declaw was
um trying to carve her was that if there
was a a definition of up to date for for
administrative purposes having that six
months plus giving people room for you
know if they had an infection to have
waited that three-month time frame uh
that is how that nine months was arrived
at but really
um you know that if you haven't had your
booster uh within that six month time
frame you can get it now
and that's the point no it's a it it's
it's it's about up-to-date vaccination
or up-to-date vaccinated so we all want
to ask ourselves whether we are up to
date in terms of our vaccinations and to
be up to date means that we've had a
dose of vaccine in the last nine months
now nine months exactly for the purpose
Dr Tam uh mentioned uh nasty recommends
six months so after six months you
should be receiving your your third dose
if you've had you've had your your two
doses but then you may need a bit more
time just to get an appointment and if
you've been recently infected you might
not want to receive that additional dose
right away so nine months seems to be a
reasonable time for people to be
expected to be receiving their
additional dose and therefore to keep
being up to date
and by the way if I may add
um about 60 of adults uh currently would
be uh having having had would have would
have had a third dose so they would be
considered to be up to date in that
particular sense but that's that means
another 30 percent uh or forty percent
of adults or would not be up to date as
as of now so that's why in the next few
weeks we will be working with privacy
and territories to make it uh easier and
to encourage all those Canadians to be
receiving their third dose and to give
them the level of protection that the
third those would provide
um given what experts tell us now I
would also uh say that as we do that
we'll be able to catch up with some of
the uh for the fact that we are behind
most other G7 countries in our race of
third Doses and and we we shouldn't be
behind because we've been ahead of all
those other uh countries with with two
doors so we know that we have the
capacity and the ability to do better
and we'll do better because we'll be
working together
thank you one last reminder to use a
raise hand function for the reporters
who may be interested in a question on
on the line uh
meantime while we check on that
um Dr Tam I I recall your Twitter
account had a message of several months
ago on you know how to speak to people
in an in an empathetic way
regarding health concerns you know as we
go into the Family Day long weekend you
know Canadians May encounter people who
have different views on on public health
and what they're supposed to do I'm
wondering if you can give us some
comments and perhaps you as well
Minister about
you know how do Canadians talk to each
other about health issues that have
become uh difficult or divisive or
people have other other concerns
yeah maybe I always thought and and this
is
um I think it speaks to the strength of
Canada and as laid out in one of the
recent Publications in the Canadian
Medical Association Journal we actually
did quite well compared to other similar
countries and that's because of cohesion
within our communities and uh adults 18
plus 90 of them got through those as a
vaccine and uh they're doing quite well
and great effort at 60 on the third
those we we want to support them to sort
of make that better so I think on the
whole
um Canadians have done really amazingly
well in
um both following the public health
advice
so it is difficult and it happens in
family situations or other settings
where people do disagree on different
views and as much as possible having a
um you know obviously still listening to
each other
find common ground but also Point people
towards
um you know credible information is
really important and I think from the
public health agency the health Canada
and others in the federal government
we've been trying to provide the
information necessary for people to have
those difficult conversations but it's
not easy but I think build on our
strengths and how far we've come and
it's not just about protecting
individuals it's about protecting each
other and protecting our communities so
if if people can bear that in mind I'm
sure that they will be able to
continue to practice those good personal
protective measures that we've all
learned to do over the last two plus
years and the happy Canada day and we
need to celebrate what we have already
accomplished I think
it's really well done and so celebrating
our success and celebrating our sense of
solidarity in in supporting each other
and continuing the successful fight
we've been having against the disease
thank you I believe we have one last
question from Allison northcott CBC
please go ahead
hi I'm just wondering what you would say
to Canadians who might be wanting uh to
wait for those more specific uh targeted
vaccines that are in development before
they go and get a booster knowing that
that might be on the horizon
yes it's um Teresa Taylor I'll start and
we actually have Dr Matt Tunis who's on
a call to support us from the nasty
perspective as well
I think for now we we are still waiting
for the regulatory process and the
looking at how much benefit the
um the bivalent vaccines for example
would provide and they may provide some
marginal benefits and and we need to
sort of get a handle on that but for now
we do know that what we the vaccines
that we have uh can boost protection
particularly in the period of time soon
after vaccination vaccination against
infection as well as actually quite
enduring
um protection still against
um severe outcomes so I think Canadians
should focus on that particular fact as
they make the decision to get the
boosters and Nasi will provide further
recommendations uh should the newer
vaccine formulations uh get authorized
in Canada but I think as depending on
your local epidemiology as cases go up
like ba4 and ba5 as indicated in some
areas of Canada
getting that booster if you haven't had
it now would be quite important in
particular going into the fall so I
think I would leave it at that and I
don't know if Dr tuners has anything
else
yeah yeah thanks Dr Tam
um I mean I would add that from from the
nasty statement
the committee continues to strongly
recommend that the first booster dose be
offered for those 18 and over or
adolescents at a high risk of infection
as as Dr Tim mentioned in her opening
remarks so that you know that advice
stands
the committee has provided this week a
forward-looking
statement and forward-looking advice
about a program in advance of potential
fall Resurgence and at times when we
know the health system capacity can be
particularly strained
but the committee has not been
prescriptive about exactly when that
that new program would would start and
the committee advises in their
recommendations
that individuals should be listening to
their local public health authorities
about when exactly the time the right
time will be to uh to take that new
booster dose so we know that
jurisdictions have variable epidemiology
across the country and might have
slightly different start dates to when
they launch that fall booster program
and and that's acknowledged and and
appreciated by the committee
so that of course makes this question of
timing complex
so when exactly individuals should be
receiving additional booster Doses and
exactly what formulation as Dr Tam
mentioned there is still a considerable
uncertainty that also the committee
acknowledged in their statement about
the exact timing of new and availability
of new formulations and exactly what
those new formulations might contain so
as that's being worked through with
Regulators over the summer which does
take time right that once for example
moderna or Pfizer submit those data the
regulator needs to outdo their due
diligence and is going to conduct that
that full regulatory assessment in
Canada so that will take time
as we we work through that and then Nasi
as an advisory committee will
additionally look at that evidence and
and the availability of the products at
the time also considering the
epidemiology at the time when those
products become available and then can
further advise on where they could be
most impactful and
um at that point I think we might expect
to see more granular advice about
product selection and if there are
actually Superior Products that should
be used for certain individuals then
that would be elaborated at that time
but really right now there's so much
uncertainty about the environment
overall that the committee was quite
clear that their their advice stands
around first booster doses for those who
haven't received them and also around
second booster doses for those that have
already been strongly recommended so for
example those 80 and over or those in
long-term care settings all of that
advice
remains from the committee and they're
trying to look forward and provide this
plan planning guidance which is what it
is it's planning guidance it's not
prescriptive it you know as as much as
we would like it it to be possible even
the committee is unable to predict
exactly how the future will unfold so
they're providing us with the best
advice at the time to look forward to
that um that future potential reality of
additional products and also additional
epidemiological concern in the fall
yeah
uh follow Bowser
uh thanks um and and how challenging do
you think it will be to convince people
to go back for more boosters
um as Theresa zamabia I will um try and
answer that question it can be quite
challenging but as as we said you know
even
um
60 third dose is is actually quite a
good effort we just need to understand
why the uh the the rest of the uh adult
population who got to those is didn't
get their thirds and uh I think we have
some details as to why they didn't
they're not getting that third dose so
uh for example I think some people were
wondering whether if they just got
infected why should they get that third
dose and so I think the nasty
recommendation I'm trying to explain to
people why you know even uh infection
related immunity particularly as it
pertains to omakone could weigh in over
time uh getting that boost is important
as Nasi had recommended
um and there may be other reasons as
well so we've got to be
um
as well as accelerating broad-based
campaigns is actually continue to do
those more targeted
community-led efforts that tries to
understand why people are not taking up
a vaccine as much as possible but I
think today Canadians have followed
advice if we explain to them that in
fact protection from the vaccine could
Wan over time
the virus is changing and it's important
ahead of a respiratory virus season
which I think many people do understand
like influenza and other viruses they
can be very much encouraged to get
vaccinated having access as we all know
making it easy
for people to make healthy choices is
very important so all of those things
that we do so amazingly well
um can be leveraged for the booster
campaign one thing that I'm quite
encourage is that a lot of um
a lot of provinces
um are also supporting pharmacists
giving out vaccines and that increases
access of course in different
communities and you can get those even
without a um you know Public Health
Clinic there are many communities where
access can now be done with with
pharmacies and so I think it's an oil
effort using multiple
um
approaches to get people the vaccines
that they need and and the public health
agency the federal government will
continue to fund Community The Base
projects that um increases awareness
um education as well as supporting uh
decision making from leaders and
credible voices in those communities
and I would add it as Dr tomjo said it's
about making it easy to understand and
making it easy to do to First understand
so a clear language the nine months is
very clear and will help people
understand why up to date is the right
way to think about vaccination now no
fully vaccinated
makes no sense now so it's about up to
date so am I up to date in my
vaccination as I received a vaccine in
the last nine months and uh and if not
then am I eligible to receive a in a a
new dose of vaccines and then add
easiness to access as Dr Thomas said
really well it's about ease of access
and for particular communities that's
very key you know for more marginalized
more remote communities in particular
accesses is key and many many Canadians
are very willing to have to be be up to
date and will be very willing to be up
to date but they will require their
governments to make it relatively easy
and as easy as possible to access
vaccination
thank you very one one other question
coming
um Cassandra koslarski Canadian press
please go ahead
uh can you hear me
uh we were just wondering about monkey
pox uh is Health Canada or
has nasty perhaps considered advice or
plans for wider distribution of the
vaccine for monkeypox is
we've seen the US and the UK both
expanded their programs
yes it's Teresa town just to remind
people that nasty did make a
recommendation for monkeypox vaccine
already
um and
um and that includes the
um what we call pose exposure
prophylaxis which is the provision of
vaccine to people who may be in contact
with a confirmed or probable case
within that sort of four day to you know
preferably as soon as possible but the
four to 14 day time frame so that that
recommendation has been provided as well
as some very targeted uh prevention or
pre-exposure vaccination for some
population groups but I think together
with the provinces particularly Quebec
Ontario but also the other two provinces
that have had cases we've been having
conversations with the provinces on the
approach to the vaccination including
the provision of vaccines
um to
groups or settings that may be at higher
risk so that's been done at the local
level
and and the supply comes from the public
health agencies National Emergency
stockpile system and we've been having
very close bilateral discussions with
provinces in terms of the supply as they
begin to draw down on the supply
allocated to their particular
jurisdictions so I do think that Canada
compared to other countries has
mobilized quite a bit of vaccination and
I'm hoping that we can draw some
evaluations and Lessons Learned From
that the our current experience as well
that's really important
I I would add Dr Tam also that um you
know that Nasi as a committee has has
committed to to also monitor the
evidence landscape as it evolves so if
there is a shift in evidence either from
International
spaces or from Canadian evidence as is
being generated within the country now
then the committee would update guidance
as needed but as of now there are no
imminent updates planned from Nasi
thank you well as a follow-up Dr Tam on
Supply that you mentioned can you
provide numbers on how many doses
oh the vaccine from lunch box we have
available
uh we just don't generally comment on
what's in the stockpile but all to say
is that the provinces that uh carrying
out vaccination have what they need and
I believe
um you know Quebec has been quite active
and they've been providing vaccines I
think now to over 7 000 people and in
Ontario they're also been escalating
their efforts and I think in that
Province I don't have the number right
in front of me but maybe around 5
000 or so so
um and and they have what they need for
now but we're maintaining close contact
with them as they make progress
foreign
I think that's public information
Minister me or may not wish to comment
on it then of course there is a
continuing discussions and uh contract
negotiations with uh Bavarian Nordic the
manufacturer to access more
all right those are all the questions we
have for today thank you for everyone's
time and Happy candidate